to present Lauren Bacall with reward
please welcome Angelica Houston
you
Lauren Bacall once said stardom isn't a
career it's an accident
I say when it comes to stardom and
Lauren Bacall there are no accidents
that voice those eyes that fabulous face
Lauren Bacall defines what it means to
be a great actress and also a huge movie
star from her unforgettable debut
playing Murray slim browning and Howard
Hawks to having to have not she had the
courage and fortitude to go toe-to-toe
with Humphrey Bogart in the end she had
him worshipping at her feet all she had
to do is whistle it was sublimely
evident that Lauren Bacall had brought a
unique combination of intelligence humor
mystery allure and just plain magic to
the screen her performances in films
such as The Big Sleep
dark passage and my father's film Key
Largo sealed her impact as a woman of
great charisma and beauty but one not to
be trifled with
and she paved the way for a career of
international acclaim Lauren received an
Academy Award nomination for her
tour-de-force betrayal of Hannah Morgan
and Barbra Streisand the mirror has two
faces and has continued to give us
daring remarkable characters in films
such as Lars von Trier is Dogville and
Jonathan Glazer is birth a story goes
that when my father was filming African
Queen in the Belgian Congo MS Bacall who
by now had become not only Bogart's Muse
but also his wife went along to Africa
to help cook for the crew and keep up
the collective morale my mother had been
unable to accompany my father as she was
well into her
third term of pregnancy and at some
point during the course of filming a
half-naked barefoot runner came bounding
through the jungle with telegram which
he handed to my father my dad accepted
the envelope
opened it smiled and put it away in his
pocket unable to bear the tension for
another moment
McCall flirted out for God's sakes job
tell us what it says and my dad smiled
it's a girl he said her name is Angelica
I guess you could say that Lauren Bacall
was one of the first people to know me
I'm so sorry that I never had the good
fortune to meet Humphrey Bogart who was
my father's best friend in life but I'm
so thankful that I got to know and love
Lauren Bacall all for myself I was
thrilled to work with her on mr. Norris
a film directed by my brother Danny and
co-written by my father John Huston
Lauren Bacall Pitta mises an incredibly
glamorous independent woman but also an
eternal romantic who loves her family
passionately and loves her work her
unswerving devotion and loyalty to my
father her many kindnesses to my husband
Robert and myself have filled me with
gratitude and pleasure throughout the
years I hold her in my heart as a mother
a friend a guide a teacher one whose
steadfastness honesty and extraordinary
beautiful you d have graced my life and
so it is my great pleasure to present
this Academy Award to my beloved friend
Lauren Bacall